en tant que flic au travail d'abord,
je me comprends les heures où tu dois travailler
mais même quand tu es là tu n'es pas
là j'aimerais que tu sois à la maison ils ne peuvent pas voir l'
officier Sarchie
a rencontré beaucoup de prêtres tu ne sembles pas le
type et j'ai fait beaucoup de flics et
tu es exactement le genre je marche dans
les égouts tous les soirs j'ai vu des
choses horribles rien je ne peux pas être
expliqué par la nature humaine
quand tu as des scènes de mal
c'est  des dames folles se plaignent de
bruits étranges après vous,
qu'est-ce que c'est vrai, Mina, j'ai connu
deux types de mal dans cette vie, le
mal secondaire, le mal que font les hommes, et le
mal primaire, qui est quelque chose de
complètement différent, vous ne pouvez pas le combattre de la
manière habituelle.  entends trois voix, l'une
des voix vient d'une fillette de cinq ans,
toutes les cultures, toutes les religions,
pratiquons l'exorcisme.
J'ai eu une obscurité grandissante en moi,
certaines stagnantes pour moi, dis-moi que tu as vu que tu
peux sentir ce que les autres ne peuvent pas mais ça
vous met également en danger, votre famille est
déjà en danger, commençons par
vous